nur mit denen auch die nordmänner du
musst ich auch wieder übernehmen
du sparst die alte nicht so schlecht
das kann man die sowieso ja was denn
vielleicht in der brand er stirbt
einfach apple die ganze kirche
[Musik]
willkommen zumal im jahren gäste mein
kapital stamme ja immer mit konkreter
ich bin noch auf dem weg in seine stadt
und er ist jetzt junge den auf die nach
den den er warum warum denn keine sachen
in meinem haus ich mit meinem haus ich
bin mein haus spart de rossi das ist
scheiße an der regel kann man einmal
sein haus gehen und sich da verstecken
die regel gibt es doch gar nicht aber du
darfst keine blöcke kaputt machen und
nur mit glocke kaputtmachen kommst du
hier rein du wirst du [ __ ] die junge
ich habe gesagt wir machen frieden
bekommen wir die straße und blüht es
mich auch noch mit der regel nur
sebastian loose regelt es herrscht krieg
da wurde natürlich auch meine nachkriegs
nach kriegsrecht kann man das nicht
regeln belieben
du sparst du [ __ ] okay bradl hatte ich
gerade angst alter du sparst du bist so
kacke einfach aber ich wusste ich musste
es einfach
ich hätte einfach bei dem haus stehen
sollen nämlich nicht wieder rein gehst
weil sonst kannst du ja nix sonst kannst
ja kein moment kann ich echt nichts an
meinem rüstung von einem eimer ist ich
stehe in meinem wenn du woche voraus
wenn blogger briten das ist regelverstoß
ja hallo lieber einen tag sperre und
komposter getötet na schönes fans saßen
[Musik]
da und wusste ich warum musste ich
einfach ich hab' ich hab mir gesagt ich
will dich als du als du nicht durch
zufall habe ich gesagt jetzt ist vorbei
was willst du so ein chat geschrieben
für die zuschauer ja ehrlich ich habe
immer so die gezwinkert dass ich mich
die mit dich mit den koordinaten
angelogen haben dagegen wenig verarscht
sind wir frei
was habe ich denn hier so schön ist was
das in einer granate mensch du kannst
das probieren
kannst du mir auch so viel heißen wir
nicht war fast tot alter kannst du mir
ausprobieren habe ich keinen dingen kein
problem mit lost probier doch an mir
ausmacht das macht doch mal mach doch
mach doch ist mir egal
mama mama mach doch macht dollar la la
la la ich brauche die fans dazu wir sind
im krieg macht doch weg das ist doch
glatt traurig mache wenig sinn kamen
aber dann verliere ich meine schöne
trial rüstung
jetzt macht auch wenigstens mal was hier
vorne weg naja die tür aufmachen nein
nicht wirklich ausmalen welche draußen
stehen und die blöcke um die so komisch
gebaut hast was nicht geht
doch es geht ich hab's doch schon gehört
[Gelächter]
das darf nicht wahr sein alter du sparst
dir alter du scheiß baku er ist es so
verdient zu sterben warum weil er mich
mies was hast du dich um unnötig eine
ganze folge umgeguckt bin auf der suche
nach dir um die und bitte helfen
[Musik]
nun ist ihr nie wieder einmal was
rauskam luca über werde ich auch jetzt
auch grundsätzlich auf ne ja
grundsätzlich spaß einfach durchgehen
aufs jahr war durchgehend uns die ganzen
ich könnte einfach vom stahl wir
untergehen aber gut dass unnötig
ich gehe jetzt einfach zur stege und
hole mir was damit da reingehen kann
irgendwie wie wäre es damit das sieht
doch ganz nicht aus ich habe nämlich
nette sachen noch von onyx 2
mein lieber das nicht hast du das denn
ja ich bin echt ihr wissen mit was du
dein bogen der verzaubert hast ja ich
sag's dir wenn man kaum mehr ans fenster
sagt horst haben will ich eine pizza
[Musik]
bestellt willst du mich dann wenn ich
dich töten wird es mich wieder beleben
weil sonst die folge jetzt endlich
vorbei ja ja du hast du das ich schwöre
überleben so man denn auch wieder drehen
und aufhören die leute auch wieder
beleben so muss ich auch wieder berlin
lukas an so unfair
du musst ich auch nicht aber nehmen du
sparst die alt du bist so schlecht da
das kann doch nicht sein wie soja aber
war der wilde heftigen brand er stirbt
einfach er will die ganze krieg oder
stirbt einfach du wirst nur ich hätte
ich gekillt heißt du nicht gesagt man
darf nicht im haus touren dauern heißt
nicht gemacht darum habe ich es nicht
gemacht weil du mich belogen hast spaß
ich geb ich wieder niemals du wirst doch
ich hatte ich hätte ich auch wieder
belegt ich habe es wirklich jetzt
wirklich gemacht ich heiße gleich gern
sofort ja ich muss erst mal abstand ich
mir schon ist wieder weggehen buchalter
dual stack in mein herz zittert wo er
alter ich wusste es aber ich habe mich
extra so vorbereitet hat ein schild
mitgenommen in ändert 1 worten sonst nix
und ich hab dich trotzdem gepumpt ja
ansonsten nicht ich war unvorbereitet
ich habe gesagt ja ok spontan ist okay
ist okay und do 30 die ganzen
hinterhältig traualtar aber ich habe gar
keinen er gar keine spitzhacke oder kann
ich den so mitnehmen und ich muss mit
spitzhacke bodega alter den aber ohne
willst jetzt mal hier so halver weiter
das war richtig gut
auf jeden fall witzig das war wirklich
scheiße mal erlebt ich sofort wieder
junge die gab es noch nie dass ich
gedacht habe du hast angefangen
ja okay ich wollte eben nein diese alter
ist darf nicht wahr sein alter und macht
schnell mal meine sachen dieses
verschwinden sonst luca wenn du mich
verarschen deine sachen können wir jetzt
nein loszumachen egal ich hab dich
getötet die sachen können wir dort auch
meine sachen behalten wie du mir so ich
dir
nein wir sind aber einen frieden sting
drin ich hätte dir auch alles gesagt geh
hin in frieden ich hätte dir auch alles
wieder du kannst nicht dass du hast du
dir das ist weniger unfähig hätte dir
alles wieder
ich wollte sich nur einmal töten sich
dann wieder beleben und habe die sachen
name ist alles wieder geben das so
konnte nur das ist nur fair dass sonst
unfair wenn wir hier alles zusammen
machen und du mich dann am ende und
niederträchtig gilt das echt unfair wo
hast angefangen alter das ist einfach
ein super das ist unfair
lena du hast alles zurück wie hab ich
bin zu dir gekommen um dich zu retten
weil wir in einer art friedens
situationen sind auch werde noch nie
gegeben haben wieder aber nicht alles
ich glaube du hast uns auch nicht an
meine kiste
nein aber du bist einfach einen normalen
sachen wieder und wir teilen die sachen
die werbung aufteilen wollten und alles
ich habe jetzt schon absehbar wäre das
schon strafe genug mal lieber du bist
doch selbst schuld ich habe gesagt ja
ohne witz es kann zwar sein dass ich am
anfang dass ich dir nicht dankbar war
aber dann hast du mich bis auf ein
halbes jahr zu aufgemacht ich sehe mich
jetzt besser machen wolltest krieg jetzt
war ich bin sehr einfach
krieg und ist bereit dich bitte einfach
einfach gestalten
was schreibst du da gerade mal mit dem
nicht einhalt kriege und ist einfach
gestorben und ganz darauf freue ich mich
schon drauf stein ja all das ging voll
schnell man oh mein gott alltag
du musst doch gefragt schreibt weder
gestorben alter alter alter alter alter
das war über krass war aber deine frau
rüstung hast du noch hauptsächlich na ja
bis auf den kopf
ich will ich jetzt aber nicht reinlassen
ich würde dir ich will nur meine sachen
wieder
ich kann nicht gar nicht töten wenn ich
meine sachen ich habe du kannst du jetzt
theoretisch schon steht die anfänge
beschwerten und mich töten ja das stimmt
wohl habe ich möchte einfach nur meine
sachen wieder okay dann ist alles in
ordnung
dann können wir alle in frieden
zusammenleben das ist kein deal ab das
kann dir jetzt habe ich gefragt balogh
ich habe angst vor dem alter ich will
nur meine sachen jetzt nicht nicht dass
meine sachen jetzt die spore gemeinsam
vor der folge sollen machen
friedensvertrag und jetzt lassen wir die
sachen bitte einfach nicht das wäre so
traurig wenn die ganzen sachen die wir
zusammen geführt haben
da steckt auch gemeinsame erinnerungen
drin und wenn du jetzt einfach verloren
gehen wer ist einfach nur traurig mal
lieber meister von firma hier einfach
von firma her das wäre war eine traurige
sache und das möchte ich nicht verstehst
du warum sagst handy mal nichts weil ich
gerade richtig fokussiert bin hier alter
ich denke meiner machst du irgendetwas
was ich nicht möchte was bestimmt nicht
gekommen
bitte ich möchte nur 1 unterlag der nein
noch nicht ich muss erstmal wieder den
weg finden zu simons quartal hat ist
nämlich nicht ganz einfach
du kannst nicht weil reist ich habe
schon gedacht das war so dumm von dir
dass du dich einfach dahin stellt sein
weil ich konnte die ganze zeit gegen die
wand schlagen und man
mittels eines wortes einfach mega op ja
ich gehe davon aus ich dachte du okay
ich dachte du siehst so ein okay bei uns
war dumm von mir jetzt da für mich aber
nein hat noch gar nicht gesehen
[Musik]
ich komme auch ohne irgendwas andere
waffen oder irgendwas hat nur noch die
rüstung an von gerade eben und unten
eisig sagte alles was ich habe ich habe
mich zum inventar sei es werde eine
komplette sanierung des oberhauptes weil
das war richtig also wir hatten jetzt
den kampf und wenn du mich jetzt mal das
obwohl ich dich wieder belebt habe und
die leute sachen wieder gäbe das wäre
mir meine sachen wieder gibt es dann
wenn ich dich nicht angreifen nicht nur
ein schlag
okay da wo wir jetzt einen
friedensvertrag machen alter wenn ich so
eine sache
da ich glaube ich hab's gefunden jawohl
ich glaube jetzt bin ich da ja komm ich
sagen kannst dir die tür aufmachen wenn
du hier rechts gegen schlicht darauf
natürlich wie sagst du nichts an weil
ich angst gehabt
stell mal siehst du ziehst du kommt mir
hier kommen hier
ich habe meine ich werde ich kann ich es
locker töten aber ich mache es nicht ja
wer auch mega sie dass ihr das war ja
nicht als ich von mir das war ja
menschen also die von dir wenn es
überhaupt als sie war sogar von
niemanden also den höher eingestellt ich
meine sachen raus stellte ich stelle ich
hier hinpasst denn alles eingesammelt
ja ich habe nahezu alles was so alles
ich will nicht dass du ja es war lag da
nicht alles ich weiß nicht ob das alles
war
ich hoffe dass nichts verbrannt oder so
was war denn da zum beispiel bei was ist
eine kiste gemachten er ist nur zur
peter dinger drin
naja so hier liegt aber jetzt nichts
mehr keine ahnung ob das ist müsste es
aber eigentlich alles ja eigentlich
alles eingesammelt
du hattest einen scale
ja einen feuer schwer jedoch so ein
backpacker auf ihre goldene feder ja
genauso ein backpacker schielt ich bin
mir zugelaufen
inter steht weiß nicht wohin das schwert
auf jeden fall wenn ihr das entsteht
wenn man das schwert hattest du laschet
habe ich kann habe ich in das locker
sword ryans wort denn die giants wort
oder lassen nicht bereinigt hätte ich
auch nicht ich möchte
daneben stehen wir müssen auch wissen
vertrauen haben wenn wir schon ja ich
habe kein vertrauen in dich du bist
einfach zu mir gekommen gemeint ist
vorher sogar vor der aufnahme noch 2
minuten er war nicht direkt neben mir du
hättest du ein bisschen gut geplant
hättest du das so gut machen wie wie gut
klar könnte ich habe es ja nicht hätte
ich ja gekillt ich hätte dich locker
gekehrt aber hab ich nicht auf dich
geschossen weil du gesagt hast du bist
in deinem haus sonst vielleicht einfach
dein haus rein gegangen
wir sollten eine chance das gesetzbuch
kennen das gesetzbuch kennt du sagst mir
etwas nicht denken steht vielleicht habe
ich einmal was übersehen bin so gutmütig
ja ja und das ist noch lange nicht alles
jetzt hier und danach hat es dieser
sogar nochmal ja ich weiß ja nicht was
sonst hat das gucken dann aufnahme sagt
mir was du sonst hatte ich kann ich
nicht auf namen gucken wir hoffen noch
läuft hier welche ich nehme es in einer
durchgehenden datei auf ja stimmt da ist
mir doch einfach rein ich sage dir was
ich hatte ja nee ich habe angst dass du
darfst nicht meine kisten nahe komme ich
neben nichts draußen siehst wird mir
aber dass man alles ich habe das einfach
alles meine kisten gepackt war dass ich
nie wieder geben
komm schon komm schon du hattest du
hattest ja man meinen bogen zum beispiel
diamanten hatte ich bitte lassen sie
einfach rein das ist nur eine
zeitverzögerung im nächsten jahr ist du
hast mich bitte einfach rein
wir haben ja noch zeit nein lass ich
bitte einfach rein luca luka lasse ich
einfach rein
ich hatte noch einen boden welchen bogen
letzten pfeil oder mehrere pfeile
erstmals seine eigenen kinder investiert
38 das wird kalt ich habe zwei legia
bogen ja meinte verzaubertes habe mir
diesen beiden verzaubert alter ich hätte
genau den gleichen bogen ab wie du oh
mein gott ich hätte ich locker gepanscht
ich barbara boote hattest du hier noch
bist du das nicht einfach ein die ja ich
habe mir alles mögliche nicht wie
einfach so schnell meine sachen du
schaffst es in dieser folge wenn jedes
mal eine sache holt und dann wieder
zurück aber wir den wert ist mich jetzt
wahrscheinlich bin ich vorbereitet ich
hab keine rüstung haben das einfach nur
peinlich sei dank mittleren kisten sind
die wertvollen und außen sind vielleicht
auch noch ein paar sachen von dir
bekannt
naja gut jetzt die beiden mittleren
kisten sind die wertvollen da ist alles
bei dir einmal einsortiert ja also ich
weiß dass du nahezu keine essenzen
hattest doch jede menge jede menge ich
hatte auch war jedes feuer ist und ich
hatte auf jeden fall wasser ist es kann
sein dass meinem rucksack welche davon
sind als bei wasser ist tanzen aber die
feier ist es ist zum beispiel nicht
ablassen beispiel keine feuer ist es
doch ein doch aber das war meine ich
habe deine da habe ich nicht bekommen
jetzt ja ich hab's dir zugeschnitten der
ist es von mir nehme das nicht dass ich
unten
doch nicht wissen das ding so einen also
ein teil ist ein schwert ich mache was
ich da du hast mich schon wieder was
geklaut nein ich habe nichts genommen
eigentlich darf resort was von mir auf
jeden fall
und ich glaube auch die friseure
irgendwas davon einen friedwald rüstung
komplett gehört mir so und auf jeden
fall noch mehr checks tänzen ist euch
gar keine mehr
und wir wollten zählten ein du hattest
keine magic essenzen ich habe doch und
ich haben schon mehrere ich hatten
mehrere warte dann hier hier hier sind
noch welche warte wie viele hattest du
ja ich weiß ich nicht aber ich habe ich
hier bin ich alles gezählt
ich gebe jetzt einfach die hinter
hausding ist miniatur rettinger von
modena
ich habe die dort nicht geschmissen ach
ja das miniatur hat es gibt auch die
adrs auch meine frau ist okay gut gehen
wir einen schritt runter von den berufen
die scale die beiden scale sachen sind
mir die habe ich schon gesagt ja ich
habe schon meine eigenes gestern habe
ich habe aber noch sind das meist
benutzten hat dieselben verzauberung wie
ich das kannst du dir auch nehmen du
hast sogar ein christel benutzt ihn
einfach nicht
er ist auch nicht besser als die abo ja
ich meine weißen liga boten christel
kontrastieren einfach beiden nicht
gehabt ja ich mache ich auch so werde
ich gemacht habe ich hatte auch ersten
zwei drei taxis wartet die hier glaube
ich aber die hat so eine mediale mit
next mit mit aber mit einer besseren
verzaubern ja das ist richtig geben
der rest gehört im inventar aber
komplett vor es ist einfach leer
jetzt sind ja auch immer ein paar sachen
weg da es hat ja auch gebrannt der boden
nein das brennt so es zählt nicht wenn
der boden da zählt nur das war nur brent
von mir selbst so das macht nichts
kaputt was ist eigentlich lumberjacks
zum beispiel die auch live und euch hat
es so ich hatte alles praktisch und du
nimmst mir als einfach weg was bringt
eine lumix alter keine ahnung ich heiße
das nicht und ich bin mir sicher hat
auch star pierce aber kannst du behalten
möchte nicht mal sondern 8 ich hatte
sieben stars lady gaga dem ich hatte
aber welche man kann nicht sein dann
habe ich die waren das nichts daran
getan sich woher weißt du dass du sieben
hattest wer nicht genau weiß dass ich
sie immer hier ist noch ein aber das
wird euch auch mal nicht einer ist ein
extrakt ist einfach getan
ja ich weil ich dachte dass die sachen
jetzt mega dass ich mir das nicht wieder
gebe
die junge du kannst besonders die das
wiedergeben da wie dort meine sachen
einfach behalten hier hoben sie noch
sachen drin die alle von mir sind da ist
mein christoph ohl das sind alles meine
sachen sie hat noch eine extratour
gemacht so dass man alles meine sachen
weil aber auch scheiße drin immer gute
sachen die da oben ja also
wahrscheinlich weil ich hab mir passen
raus kann ich von mir war zum beispiel
friedrich gefunden welche sache welche
die firma nur ist allerdings derzeit nur
weil ich jetzt hier um der da war bei
mir gar nichts drin war bei mir war als
in diese nicht komplett voll aber so
oder so bist du mehr sogar
und da waren voll viele sachen drin von
mir die haben auch diamanten raus kommst
kannst du aber haben wir das nicht das
war sogar mal ja das war so kann man
instanz sogar sein dass dann zwar ohne
krieg nori cas panel krieg nur mit
leggins und die wahl obwohl von mir oder
nicht dass ich brauchte nicht aber du
kannst du willst mir kriegt jetzt gar
nicht irgendwie dafür dass ich getötet
habe doch ich habe bloß sperre
danke ich war so lange war ich mich
nicht mehr gestorben und zeigen so einer
k k platzsperre wohl kommen jetzt hier
raus wir müssen jetzt die folge bleiben
ich hoffe ich habe alles schaut man mit
rheine kommt habe ich irgendwann
vergessen habe und daher aus da ja ich
bin ja schon ewig her
ja es tut mir leid erstmal das dinner
getötet habe aber den er wollte den
den zeit und den angefangen mit dem
kämpfen weil ich wollte einen
friedensvertrag machen deswegen
gerechtfertigt weil das war witzig was
wir müssen jetzt schnell finster tag in
folge zu ende
schnell wie lange die folge noch wir
haben jetzt fünf folgen dann werden wir
jetzt ja wohl in den nächsten fünf tagen
immer schaffen aufzunehmen dann machen
wir nicht schnell friedensvertrag
schnell
wir sind schon 21 minuten fahrt wieso
dauert so lange weil die lega erster
runder comeback des zorns erstmal mir
sagen ich nach hause komme ja da jetzt
links und zb essen müssen wir gar kein
essen gegeben
das ist mir kein essen gebe ich hatte
viel essig ich mache erst kommen etwa
hunger gerade günstig war hunger gerade
dann komm zu mir bitte hier beim ich bin
beim drive in
da kommt zum 34 ja danke ihr spielzeug
ja wo ist das spielzeug beispiel ist
einfach keinen bock darauf gut meine
lieben freunde sind 22 minuten tut uns
leid dass ich ein bisschen bezogen haben
es war ein fight mit drin und alles
mögliche nicht ich muss erst raus aus
dieser stadt das muss mir verziehen sein
ich muss erst raus ich muss erst draußen
hat auch meine zwölf minuten folge
aber jetzt muss ich jetzt einmal muss
ich hier ein bisschen jeweils die nummer
einfach raus aus dieser stadt hier zu
kommen weil das ist hier natürlich
verständlich zu gefährlich ich mal
runter vom server hier seien junge mann
da kämpfen wir einfach mal noch raus aus
dieser gefährlichen statt nur raus raus
raus
mein gott was war das bloß wenn der fall
ich heftig have der chef von mittelalter
meine fresse und ich habe auch meine ich
hatte auch eine diamant spieltage hast
du auch noch behalten einfach auch eine
junge diamant spieltag ist nix hier aber
trotzdem ist muss ich mich ja mit einer
mit per hand fast raus brüllen ich
beende schauen wir mal eine folge wie
den dass ich daraus bilden können die
berliner sehen wenn es euch gefallen hat
und dem er von solchen komische sachen
wollte das einfach eine bewertung dar
dann würde ich sagen tschüss bis zum
nächsten mal